Elon already regrets buying Twitter and
it's not surprising why according to
Elon himself the current market value of
Twitter is less than half of the 44
billion that he paid for it uh you know
we just revalued the company at less
than half of the acquisition price this
means that he has lost over 22 billion
dollars worth of Twitter before even
owning it for a single year that's the
same as losing 2.4 billion dollars every
single month since the purchase and that
that's just the loss in market value
Twitter itself was already burning money
when Elon took over so it's likely that
Elon has lost even more money running
the company zooming out though this
doesn't really matter for someone like
Elon Musk given that he's still up
nearly a hundred billion dollars a year
to date thanks to Tesla and SpaceX but
despite this it's not surprising that
Elon still feels like he got the short
end of the stick in fact he's so salty
about the deal that he's trying to sue
the Twitter lawyers who forced him to
complete the deal you see it when Elon
Musk started trying to back out of the
Twitter deal a year ago Twitter went
down out and found the best lawyers they
could which turned out to be a firm
called the watchtel Lipton Rosen and
cats as we now know this Law Firm was
indeed successful at getting Elon to
follow through with this offer but in
return they charged Twitter 90 million
dollars for essentially four to five
months of work Twitter's own staff
itself were stunned when they saw this
fee in fact a Twitter director named
Martha Lane Fox would email The General
Counsel quote oh my freaking God after
seeing the fee but what if he was indeed
exorbitant this didn't really matter for
Twitter's original executive team
because they weren't the ones paying the
bill this bill was paid right before
Elon took over so ironically it was Elon
who had to pay the lawyers that forced
him into the deal it's no wonder why
he's so salty but Does Elon actually
have a chance at winning this case and
recouping his 90 million dollars or is
Elon just about to burn even more money
on legal fees trying to win this lawsuit
foreign
the case for Elon is pretty
straightforward it breaks down into two
parts with the first part centering
around Twitter's executive team
essentially he's arguing that Twitter's
Executives did nothing about the
ridiculous bill because well they
weren't the ones paying the bill so they
weren't exactly motivated to act in
Twitter or elon's best interest in fact
paying these lawyers 90 million was just
one of the executive's many lavish
expenses as they headed out so in that
context all of Twitter's actions before
elon's takeover should be questioned
because the people in charge simply
didn't care about the final outcome more
than just winning the lawsuit they were
essentially lame Ducks who are
collecting their last paychecks before
they were gonna get fired when you
really think about it by fighting Elon
Musk and forcing him to close these
Executives were literally putting
themselves out of a really good job so
it's safe to assume that they would not
only be unmotivated to work in elon's
best interest but that they would
actively be resentful against Elon don't
forget Twitter didn't even want to sell
themselves to Elon in fact they were Act
actively trying to avoid getting
acquired by using things like the poison
pill the only reason they eventually
agreed to the acquisition is because
elon's offer was just so stupidly high
that they would open themselves up to
shareholder lawsuits if they didn't take
the deal and then now Elon was trying to
get a lower price by threatening to back
out of the deal and that they were the
ones who had to fight for Elon to close
yeah it would be more surprising if
these Executives weren't pissed off so
Elon is attempting to argue that the
actions of these Executives were not
only Reckless but actively not in
Twitter's best interest the second part
of elon's argument claims that watchtel
leveraged the situation to get away with
Ludacris pricing there's really no
question about this in terms of hourly
billing itself Elon claims that watch
telecharge Twitter 15.6 million many of
these billing invoices didn't even have
proper time entry descriptions in fact
they were completely blank that Twitter
paid them anyway their likely reason for
this was simply that the hours were
probably unreasonable even with a
massive hourly fee watch devil pulls in
a whopping 3.86 million dollars in
Revenue per lawyer per year given that
the average lawyer bills around a 1900
hours per year we're looking at an
hourly fee of about two thousand dollars
Twitter likely went for the best lawyers
at the firm so their hourly fee was
likely higher but they did get a 15
discount so we'll just assume an hourly
fee of 2000 this means that to rack up
15.6 million dollars worth of hourly
fees watch Dell had to charge Twitter
for roughly 7 800 hours of work all
within a matter of 18 weeks in other
words watchdel is basically claiming
that they were consistently putting in
over 400 hours of work every week to
defend Twitter I don't know about you
but Elon feels that this itself is
completely unjustifiable but that
doesn't even Encompass the vast majority
of the 90 million dollar fee you see
most of the 90 million was charged to
Twitter after Elon agreed to buy Twitter
as a sort of success fee the only
problem with this success fee was that
it was never mentioned in the original
deal and it seems that Twitter's
Executives were well aware of this
considering their reaction but despite
this paying the invoice was literally
the last thing they did presumably in a
screw you type of manner in fact the
wire payment was completed just 10
minutes before Elon closed the deal and
the executives were fired so the
evidence does suggest that there may
have been some bad faith from the
Twitter team and this is what Elon is
really trying to hammer in on watchdel
was over here handing out invoices that
didn't even have proper hours and
charging unagreed upon success fees in
the tens of millions meanwhile Twitter
didn't even question a single invoice in
fact they made sure that they were paid
it before Elon took over but this
doesn't mean that Elon has the victory
in the bag by any means
foreign
for starters Twitter's Executives aren't
required to have any sort of loyalty to
Elon whatsoever they work for the public
shareholders and their only job is to
maximize profit for shareholders from
this perspective they did exactly what
they were supposed to even in situations
where they didn't want to they didn't
want to agree to elon's takeover offer
in the first place but they did it
because that was in the shareholders
best interest similarly when Elon wanted
to back out of the deal Twitter's
Executives probably didn't want to fight
him but they did it because that wasn't
the shareholders best interest at the
end of the day Twitter's Executives not
only made sure that the acquisition was
completed but that it was completed for
these stupidly high priced that Elon
originally offered so from that
perspective Twitter's Executives it
never came short on their duties to the
shareholders the only party they
arguably came up short with is Elon
someone they have no contractual
obligation to act in the best interest
of and as for the law firm though their
fees are indeed ridiculous you already
know how they're gonna argue their case
they're not gonna try to defend the idea
that they were actually working for over
400 hours every week they're gonna argue
that it's not about how much time they
spent but rather how much value they
brought around the time that watchtow
got involved Twitter was hovering around
a market cap of 30 billion dollars or 14
billion dollars less than what Elon had
agreed to pay this means that by getting
involved Watchtower was able to add 14
billion dollars worth of value to
shareholders for which a 90 million
dollar fee is minuscule it's only 0.6
percent now Elon could of course argue
that they didn't have to do much to
actually close the deal Elon had agreed
to a specific performance Clause meaning
that if Twitter met certain thresholds
Elon had to go through with the
acquisition in other words he couldn't
just back out and pay a penalty so
really Watchtower didn't even have to
convince Elon to go through with the
deal all they had to do was disprove
elon's little fake but argument and to
prove that Twitter did indeed meet the
thresholds outlined in the original
offer obviously light worked for 90
million dollars but that's not
watchtower's fault that's elon's fault
for one signing a deal that was hard to
back out of and then two threatening to
back out anyway without a strong case
watchdel has nothing to do with any of
that as far as they're concerned their
job is to help shareholders realize 14
billion dollars in Lost value and that's
exactly what they did again their job is
not to act in elon's best interest
moreover it's not like Elon is doing
another billionaire or another company
who may have made some missteps along
the way he's literally assuming one of
the most respected law firms in the
country Common Sense would tell you that
sure a law firm might do things that are
shady or even unjust but you can be sure
as hell that it's legal here's the thing
this isn't watchtel's first rodeo
dispatch lies in mergers and
Acquisitions and then actually one party
or the other gets mad at them on a
regular basis like Carl Icahn did it
back in 2012. if you're not familiar
with Carl Icahn he is one of the most
infamous corporate Raiders of all time
and during one of his corporate raids he
realized that one of the companies that
he was rating was using none other than
watchtow and guess what they were
charging a success fee if icon's raid
succeeded the company was on the hook
for 36 million dollars if it failed
though they only had to pay 18 million
icon was obviously outraged after seeing
this and decided to take watchtel to
court but guess what happened the case
would just end up dragging on for six
years after which icon would it end up
losing so if history is any indication
of how swing over success fees ends up
well it's not looking too great for Elon
foreign
as you can see Elon has a decent case
from a what's fair type of perspective
there's no question that Watchtower
charge Twitter as much as they possibly
could and Twitter was more than happy to
pay these fees just despite Elon so it
seems fair that Elon should get a refund
on much of these legal fees but see
what's fair and what's legal aren't
always the same thing sure when you look
at it from the perspective of Watchdog
got paid in 90 million just to disprove
elon's little bot claims and finish up
the acquisition it's a stupid amount but
when you look at it from the perspective
of it watch to ensure that shareholders
got the full 44 billion that they were
promised 90 million isn't all that crazy
similarly you can blame the Twitter
Executives all you want for acting in
spite as they probably did but they only
acted in spite against Elon not against
the shareholders which is who they're
supposed to be loyal to also think about
this Elon would have never been in this
position in the first place if he didn't
try to back out of the deal if he truly
was worried about the Twitter bot
population he should have cleared up
those concerns before signing a 44
billion deal to buy the entire company
considering all of this and the fact
that watchtel has already successfully
defended themselves in a similar
situation against another Rich
billionaire it stands to reason that
Elon probably won't be getting a refund
and even if he does it won't be anytime
soon and it won't really make a
difference to Twitter's survivability
so maybe it would be a better idea to
focus on turning around Twitter instead
of wasting time on a lawsuit but that's
just what I think speaking of Carl Icahn
he's actually facing some massive Ponzi
scheme allegations check out this video
to learn more but until then I'm Hari
and I'll see you guys on the next one